good morning John
this is just yeah the most epic thing
I've ever been at we went up there we
were we were laughing muscles glasses
told people and it was just excited like
to meet people you know I'm doing so
many hugs it's definitely the opposite
of my childhood there's actual love in
the room they rush this stage we had a
camera guy I don't have an elevator
meeting so for like I like your videos
and I'm like I'm going to floor 7 VidCon
is like you know it's 2,500 people
growing growing growing and they're all
you know young excited makers I mean
they're making things and I can't
imagine like a better community of
people to be around but I've just
discovered that I accidentally showed a
bit bum crack
guys alike across only the reason why
anyway
VidCon 2012 is happening and we are
releasing the site and registration now
is sure now cuz early bird registration
is only available to the first 1000
people we just want to get some money in
the account so we can start paying for
things so I'm gonna do an FAQ now about
VidCon I asked some questions in Twitter
they're coming in where is VidCon
Anaheim right across the street from
Disneyland at the Anaheim Convention
Center where there's lots of cheap
hotels when is VidCon the community days
are Friday June 29 and Saturday June
30th and the industry day is Thursday
June 28 now this is the question people
aren't asking because they don't know
about it yet but heads up with the three
different registration passes one we
have the community pass which is the
same as always and gives you access to
everything on the 29th and 30th
including concerts and keynotes in the
expo hall and breakout and meet up you
Industrie pass you have access to the
29th and 30th as well you also have
access to the 28th which is a day people
who are in the industry of online video
get together and talk about like how to
make the most of this cool thing that
we're all doing and then three we have a
new type of pass which is the Expo pass
which is extra cheap but only gives
access to the expo we've created this
pass for a bunch of different reasons
one because we always sell out of the
community stuff and we can't sell too
many community passes or doesn't deal
community issue anymore we still the
people to be able to be involved even
after the community tickets have sold
out it's also because the expo hall will
have all of the gaming content like
video gaming and so people who are only
interested in video gaming you can just
get the expo pass you have to bother
with all of us nerds having like actual
fun
I'm XY Z young old amateur professional
tall short I don't care everyone is
allowed to come to VidCon and everyone
will enjoy
he'll VidCon be live-streamed some of
its they're not sure if we can stream
the whole thing we're definitely
videotaping the whole thing and we'll
put it up after the fact will there be a
VidCon UK East Coast Hawaii India we
dream about doing VidCon UK VidCon East
Coast we haven't been able to you know
figure out how to actually do it yet
will there be ball pits
yes we're bringing them back to ball
pits and the nerf guns maybe we'll mix
them no the darts would get lost in the
balls
darts would get lost in the balls that's
what I said I think that
which covers it I'm gonna go transcribe
this video into a FAQ page for the
website because if the last thing that I
have to do for the people who can come
to VidCon I'll see you there for
everyone else hopefully I'll see you at
some gathering sometime in the near
future if you're in America on the east
or west coast those opportunities should
be arising fairly soon
no spoilers though John good luck
continuing to sign like a madman I'll
see you and your inflamed right hand on
Wednesday